[Musique]
kino sites y compris notre siège social
à vélizy est fermé depuis le 17 mars à
12 heures toutes les activités dans
commercial ventes de véhicules neufs
d'occasion et après-vente et pièces de
rechange nous avons zéro activité depuis
cette date là c'est un choix qu'on a
fait avec nos équipes qui souhaitaient à
arrêter puisqu'on n'avait pas
d'obligation de fermer les activités
après-vente de réparation automobile qui
sont considérées comme des activités
essentielles nous avons à peu près 80 85
% des équipes qui sont en statue
activité partielle
ça représente à peu près 90 personnes
voire 100 personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
en activité partielle depuis le 17 mars
[Musique]
notre chiffre d'affaires il est il est
nul depuis le 17 mars
et il sera nulle pendant au moins un
mois ou voire six semaines
donc vous imaginez bien six semaines
sans chiffre d'affaires ça fait entre 15
et 20% de chiffre d'affaires en moins
sur le premier semestre
notre chance c'est qu'on a une
trésorerie suffisante aujourd'hui pour
faire face à cette période de
confinement après il faudra que nos
activités reprennent et qu'elle reprenne
un peu mieux que normalement puisque il
nous faudra essayer compenser au mieux 6
me ces quatre ou six semaines
d'inactivité pour conserver tous les
emplois évidemment c'est la priorité et
pour qu'on ait les moyens suffisants
également pour nos infrastructures et
tous les frais fixes qu'on a à supporter